so now we come to the place where
uh arithmetic modulo n or remain
arithmetic starts to be a little bit
different and that involves taking
inverses and canceling
let's look at that so first of all we've
already observed that we have these
basic congruence rules that if a and b
are congruent and c and d are congruent
then a plus c and b plus d are congruent
a times c and b times d are congruent so
that's the sense in which arithmetic mod
n is a lot like ordinary arithmetic but
here's the main difference
let's look at this one 8 times 2 is 16
which means it's congruent to 6
mod 10 which is the same as 3 times 2.
so 8 times 2 is congruent to 3 times 2
and you'd be tempted maybe to cancel the
twos
and what happens then well then you
could discover that you think that 8 is
congruent to 3 mod 10 which it ain't
so in short you can't cancel
arbitrarily you can't cancel 2 in this
case in particular
so that leaves naturally the question
when can you cancel a number
uh when you can you cancel a number k
when both sides of an equality are
multiplied by k and i'd like to cancel k
and the answer is simple when k has no
common factors with the modulus n
so
the proof of that is based on the
following idea
let's say that a number k prime is an
inverse of k mod n
if k prime times k is congruent to 1 mod
n so k prime is like 1 over k
with respect to mod n but of course 1
over k is going to be a fraction
um
unless k is 1. and so k prime is going
to be an integer that simply acts like 1
over k
so how are we going to prove this and
it's going to turn out to be
an easy consequence of the fact that the
gcd
is a linear combination
so how am i going to prove find this k
prime that's an inverse of k
well remember given the gcd of k and n
is 1 i have a linear combination of k
and n is one so s times k plus t times n
is one
but if you stare at that for a moment
what that means is that k prime
is simply the coefficient s of k
so all you have to do is apply the
pulverizer to k and n to get the
coefficient s of k
in the linear combination of s of k and
n that's equal to 1. let's look at that
slightly more carefully and see what's
going on i have that s k plus t n is one
so that means in particular since
they're equal they're certainly
congruent
uh to each other modulo n s k plus t n
is congruent to one mod n but n is
congruent to zero mod n so it this
becomes t times zero and we're left with
s k
congruent to one mod n which is exactly
the definition of s being an inverse of
k
now
i can also cancel k
if it's relatively prime to n and the
reason is that if i have a k equivalent
to b k mod n and and uh and the gcd of k
n is 1 then i have this k prime that's
an inverse of k so i just multiply both
sides by the inverse of k
namely k prime and i get that the left
hand side is a times k
k inverse and the right hand side is b
times k k inverse and of course that's
a times 1 is equivalent to b times 1 and
so a is congruent to b
mod n so i can cancel in that case
trivially and uh
and in fact you can work out the
converse implications the punch line of
this is well first of all this is the
cancellation rule you can cancel
providing that the gcd of k and n is one
that k is relatively prime to n so this
is the summary k is cancelable mod n if
and only if k has an inverse mod n
if and only if the gcd of k and n is 1
which i can restate as k is relatively
prime
to
and that's the story